the NFL season is back and you know you
watch football of course every year and
you notice that the commercials are
getting more and more uh politically
correct and and we're all aware of this
trend and it's not just when you're
watching football it's when you're
watching anything like you basically
never see white couples except in
certain circumstances and we'll see what
the circumstances second but usually
you're not gonna see white couples and
white families in commercials anymore
you know you'll see uh uh uh unless you
need someone to portray a burglar in a
in a home security system advertisement
other than that multiculturalism and
diversity is the way to go and with
football it's even more obvious because
all the ads are tailored obviously for
football fans which means that most of
the ads feature people who are
portraying football fans so every ad is
like football fans love beer here's our
beer that we're selling and you're a
football fan and you'll like it and so
then all they're showing on the screen
is a bunch of football fans who enjoy
the beer and for many years this meant
that every ad would just feature men
because football fans have always been
by Far and Away predominantly men and
that's still the case but the ads don't
reflect anymore so in every ad now uh
you can't upload it's very funny you
can't Apple notice that you you see no
you see an ad and it's uh they're
showing
that's a Miller Lite ad or whatever it
is and they're they're showing a group
of friends watching the game and you
look at the group of friends and it's
all you know it's a mix of races and
ethnicities very Multicultural and uh
and it's there's an exact mix of sexes
there's as many women in this football
watching party as there are men and all
the rest of it which isn't how it works
in real life so this weekend I'm
watching the Ravens game and I see this
Best Buy ad which I want to play for you
uh which to me really takes this
political correctness thing over the top
like and here's the thing this is not
the kind of commercial that will go
viral on the right as as being crazy and
woke because it's not it's not
aggressively woke or anything but it but
it's actually extremely welcome this
this is the kind of wokeness that we see
that kind of that um permeates the
culture even more the the kind that you
know it's not Dylan Mulvaney where
people are really going to notice that
it's this kind of thing so let's watch
this ad real quick
hey can we talk
so I know that you love football but
maybe
too much not saying it
not seeing it oh
defense
wins championships
okay
let's go big
[Music]
up your game with top brand TVs from
Best Buy
[Music]
okay up your game fandom Unleashed so
these are spouses that would appear I
guess we're supposed to assume and the
one spouse is confronting the other
spouse for being too obsessed with
football for being too big a fan of
football and this is the kind of setup
we've seen a million times in
advertisements and sitcoms you know
going back to the 90s but here it's the
husband confronting the wife for being
too big of a football fan and all I'm
saying is look I mean in the entire
history of sports
going all the way back through time to
ancient times whether they had their own
sports maybe not football but through
the whole history of the world
how many times over thousands of years
how many times has a husband had to sit
down with his wife
and confront her for being too big of a
sports fan
like how many times has there been a
conversation where the husband is like
you never pay attention to me because
you're always watching football
how many times ever in history it's like
is it more than three in the history of
the human race probably not
and yet this is a scenario they present
for a Best Buy commercial which which is
funny because commercials are supposed
to be relatable right they're supposed
to be recognizable you're trying to sell
something in 30 seconds and so you want
the audience to immediately recognize
the situation and be able to put
themselves in it and they say oh I
relate to that yeah I'm an obsessed
football fan I want a big TV also so you
want you want to you want that to click
right away
and that's why usually in the past
anyway commercials would have a lot of
stereotypes and just broad
generalizations that are basically true
that basically resonate because they're
trying to connect with you very quickly
and sell you a product uh but but
wokeness has made that impossible
wokeness exists in an alternate reality
which means that woke adds
can't even accomplish the purpose of
advertisements anymore
um
because they they are not based in any
kind of real world that anyone actually
recognizes
have you ever craved a nice barbecue
meal with the family say you go to the
store you get all the groceries invite
family over and when you go to turn on
the grill your propane tank is empty
tragedy strikes that's where cinch comes
in to save the day Sanchez a propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule does not
require any long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere whether you're
grilling camping with your family or
lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download their app for uh to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code walls that's Cyn ch.com promo code
Walsh there's a limited time offer and
you must live within a cinched service
area to redeem it visit cinch.com offer
for details no husband is going to watch
that commercial say oh yes I can relate
to that my wife constantly has
constantly has the game on can't get it
can't get her to pay attention I'm
trying to talk to my wife about my
feelings and she's just always watching
football man
I gotta go buy that that Best Buy TV
that's not gonna happen
but of course the real point is that the
woke ad doesn't want to reflect reality
uh it doesn't want to reflect how people
are it wants to shape reality that's
that's what they're going for wants to
change how people perceive themselves
and perceive reality and so yes women
are not likely to be the bigger sports
fans in a family but uh that's what woke
that's what wokeness wants it wants that
gender reversal not because why like why
would that make it better is is it is it
is it is that an improvement somehow if
women become bigger sports fans is do we
have we improved anything no but
um it's a break from how it
traditionally has been and that's all
that they care about if you'd like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed